we were honoring Annie Glenn a renowned
speech advocate and the widow of
astronaut and US Senator John Glenn she
died yesterday of complications from
kovat 19 Len was thrust into the
spotlight in 1962 when her husband
became the first American to orbit the
Earth listen to what she told then CBS
News correspondent and mother of 60
minutes correspondent John Dickerson
there's what she told Nancy henchmen
about that historic mission this is very
much Christmas like this and get this
John and Annie Glenn were engaged the
day Pearl Harbor was attacked they were
married for 73 years she became a hero
in her own right overcoming a severe
stutter and emerging as a champion for
people with disabilities and Glenn was
100 years old Gail boy glad I met her
years ago when I was a baby reporter way
back in the day and she was so gracious
and so lovely it's never good when the
person you're interviewing can tell
you're very nervous but she was so kind
I'll never forget it was very sad to
hear the news but what a life she has
lived